[Music]
fbi agents removed around 20 boxes of
items during their search at former
president donald trump's mar-a-lago home
on august 8th according to a search
warrant released by a florida court
friday investigators recovered 11 sets
of classified information including some
that was so top secret it is designated
to be only open in a secure government
location a list of items removed from
the property reference one set of
documents marked as various classified
slash ts
sci documents an abbreviation that
refers to top secret sensitive
compartmented information it also says
agents collected four sets of top secret
documents three sets of secret documents
and three sets of confidential documents
the list didn't provide any more details
about the substance of the files
top secret documents could include
anything from military secrets defense
secrets
information that would be pertinent to
our national security interests the list
is contained in a seven-page document
that also includes the warrant to search
the premises which was granted by a
federal magistrate judge in florida
the warrant shows that fbi agents sought
to search the quote 45 office as well as
all storage rooms and other rooms used
by the former president
they didn't seek access to private guest
rooms such as those of mar-a-lago
members according to the document
attorney general merrick garland said
thursday that he approved the decision
to seek the search warrant and called
for its release
the department filed the motion
to make public the warrant and receipt
in light of the former president's
public confirmation of the search
the surrounding circumstances and the
substantial public interest in this
matter he sort of in some ways was
putting the burden on trump to say no
don't release this but instead we saw
the president say that he had no problem
with releasing it and that he feels that
this entire thing is a politically
motivated witch hunt in a post on his
social media platform thursday trump
said his representatives had been
cooperating fully and that the
government could have had whatever they
wanted if we had it trump's lawyers
argue that the former president used his
authority to declassify the material
before he left office while a president
has the power to declassify documents a
sitting president has that power there
are federal regulations laying out that
process for doing so
it is unclear how the investigation may
progress and whether prosecutors are
considering bringing any charges against
trump this is just a first little
glimpse into what is probably a
sprawling investigation into the former
president's handling of classified
material